[Music]
what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we're going to watch two
episodes of echo but maybe this is just
in one video I don't know what are you
guys thinking about the show so far Coy
let's start with you uh really enjoying
it surprised at the tone really
impressed at the darkness that's what oh
that's efficient John I'm ready to love
the rest of this oh shills all righty
guys well I'm ready to get into it leave
a like on this video that'd be very much
appreciated also subscribe cck the
notification we get notifi on our
reaction for the next episode of EO is
up also thank you to pre set down these
highlights full length through watch
where you s with your own copy of EO
that is available for our super sexual
rejects over at our patreon page whether
joh I cover several things exclusively
with highlights and watch alongs
included let's get into
[Music]
it I like to fish May oh cool wonder if
they're all going to open in the past
who says it's the past yes the distant
future future Earth has been returned to
its natural
order it's pass it's can't
confirm oh this is an IMAX aspect change
tell by the aspect ratio
nice
damn damn they threw down lenses that
was
beautiful
wow
cool damn it's like ancient lacrosse he
caught the golden
[Applause]
snitch JK Rowling culturally
appropriated chak talk culture she would
never do such
[Music]
a uhoh get off the pot man oh the
ultimate player enters the
Frank
that's really cool how they built these
sets great trapezius definition this
guy's his whole own
team you up that's that's spit
was come at me
bro team red or team blue blue always
red versus
blue I really like that the dude is just
sitting waiting for like they need
me oh the stakes it's the name of one of
Jake Sully's kids except it's spelled
differently sports for banishment it's
hardcore oh
[Music]
damn it dude is a beast got money riding
on
[Applause]
you damn blue team's really catching up
since that one guy came Christ Tom Brady
over here doing the
work I love that there's letting this
play out as its own
story get in
there yeah there you go oh up final
point something like this is actually
really difficult to choreograph I can't
even
imagine especially all this crowd work
you got to do with everyone yeah and all
the dodging and jumping and Diving for a
sport none of us know like it's
impressive storytelling without the
Sport
rules
do
Dodge okay so it seems like there's some
type of like omnipresent tethered
Through Time memory thing happening here
a tempor she connected to her connected
to her Bloodlines memories oh my God
dude's eyes about to pop out of his
head credits o opening scene done well
this is like the True Detective opening
well I know HBO
presents
Echo I noticed Vincent denafo was not
one of the main credited ah they don't
want people to know it's him trying to
keep it a
surprise there he is but he's right here
yeah who's that
guy H the visual echo on the title
nice flash of lightning oh flash of the
fire
alarm good old
biscuits damn it's smart instead of a
doorbell never
it's not made to be Offroad not
good so demanding he just brought you
all that stuff no thanks for the
Pop-Tarts different
poptarts it is
yes many moon come CH
hey this depicts the animals talking to
the wind symbolizing the harmony with
Mother
Earth sure it does he's bullshitting
it's amazing by the damn theam theam by
the
damn took me a while to get
that oh it's great they're
subconsciously drawn to by the damn
thing but the aesthetic of our Cita is a
little more south Westy do you have any
of those Navajo Rugs oh boy sure
anthropology they have how all the
ethnically ambiguous you
could shots fired drive over to uh
anthropology and get your Navajo rug but
that's all stuff from Mad report if you
buy
Mador Scully I show you're getting
authentic handmade art from Humble
Native American
arti go
away we'll take it
ah good do you have any of those um bolo
ties bolo ties does a chicken have
lips you don't have to make Caucasian
people look stupid in order to elevate
your what are
they I don't know I'm just focused on
came out what is
that oh it's all this you get your
income tax check back or what I don't
know why you got to be all somehow I
just helped you with that sale with the
N hos you know I got better care in that
piece of whoa whoa Marvel Spotlight
slow down swear
light no no I need way
smaller how about that wow I need teeny
tiny like like a little hummingbird's
tongue he's going to be like George
Lopez and Blue Beetle he's going to be
like Tech genius John you sound so
racist right now he's clearly
Mexican Yi for all your hard work extra
busy with Maya back in town and oh I was
so excited when I took Chris to the rink
yesterday just like casual D how does he
know well Maya is being like don't tell
people I'm here but I'm going to show up
to roller skating rinks I'm walk around
outside in broad
daylight uhoh what a surprise somebody's
grandbaby having a birthday bash I don't
know about we need to talk yeah some
stuff you should have told me she really
does have an intimidating
presence
God there's going to be a cool action
scene that happens here all on skates
M's back she came by to see you not
likely the guy from reservation dogs
told me about it what you after you
don't want to know oh this like Voyer
shot right here I'm wondering if it's a
k k Loki holding the
story and it's my understanding that
she's just passing through town and
nothing more just if you can encourage
her to stick to her plan pass through
town without causing any trouble and get
the hell out of Dodge it is a very
interesting street level world they're
ex deciding to explore here in okah this
culture this does not feel like a Disney
Plus show at all like the leap between
well when I heard street level I thought
oh New York City but then to have it
focused not in a skate rink instead of
it just being like Maya's people are
good people you could feel like the
tension dir that goes on around this
town
yeah oh you going to hold up that
train we're going
splunking she's jumping on a train I
just want a whole compilation and
documentary about the people who just
make these random uis for like apps and
shows
yeah buddy let's go let's go
cool
woo Mission Impossible dead echoing I
mean the visuals are great I do feel
like she is surrounded by a lot more
interesting characters than herself
though right right now yeah everyone
else is just big and charismatic and
she's so nuanced and subtle I want to
know more about her
do speed woo cool like transition they
always do that great subtle pushing
follow your heartbeat damn how is her
heart so steady at A Moment Like This
training me she is badass
[Music]
though
oh lighting's
[Applause]
rad
nice the
Stars interesting
cut come on hereditary this
dude that is a lot of grip
strength great treads on those shoes too
you think she has the six-pack
definitely definely strong
core red light
the mark of any cool new Ora show
yes someone's developing photos in this
train
car camera like a hummingbird's
tongue it's like
startech a weird shot
yeah God damn it damn it Pok me after
the call right now I'm in the middle of
a mission
sry guy of the chair I like that he's
got it like handsfree cuz he's such a
safe guy he's not hold again sometimes
he's impressionable in the right
direction I really appreciate it oh what
do you think of that toxic waste fat
maybe the stuff that made Daredevil or
the team Ninja Turtles the same ooze
oh that pink slime they make McNuggets
out of more likely
that all my band stolen gear
come on oh that's why they off-roading I
didn't put that together somehow like a
fool hold on you
idiot come on
Maya whoa she's going in damn got a
fully stocked utility belt we don't know
what she's trying to retrieve right now
right not to my knowledge this just Fisk
supplies it's a Priceless piece of art
the rabbit in the snow
oh
yeah
oh oh no no no no it's met metal but
still that hurt has an experience thank
God she doesn't have
a right yeah I mean that was still
crunchy better than the alternative In
This Moment oh mystical Powers let's go
see what
[Music]
happens unlock the spirit of your
ancestors do some magic to this
train the
strength
oo
oh cool not bad so that's kind of like
what we were talking about with Kori
like it it's a moment of like Discovery
and like I don't know I've already felt
more like her being disoriented by the
powers than just having them that's fair
yeah it's
true oh oh jeez Terminator leg yeah come
on
where is
she you're doing great biscuits biscuits
biscuits out here with no
training o damn this like a video game
Mission oh Jesus Christ way over there
get over there bud you got one job to do
feel like that'd be burning her
[Music]
hand oh goody why do these action sceds
always lead into a
tunnel this is crazy this is
[Music]
[Laughter]
crazy yeah make sure you clarify
that wo boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy not
bad not bad she's been watching Fast and
Furious
[Music]
good job biscuits you really brought the
gravy
today you almost
died we almost almost
died like
corre
communication that was really
funny I took it back steal anything she
plant something yeah she need know what
was in
there we have no idea what she's doing I
love her little Smiles of relief the
train made it to New York City yeah it
must be some Fisk products going to be
unable yeah that guy track suit mafia
hey just came in top stop Good Times cat
yo I'm pack this unload these drum
heads D9
X
dis Disney's X-Men
97 District 9 on
Twitter oh oh
yeah she did PL something not message
I'm coming for you like an epoxy
bomb o Dam they they really blow a place
up
every phone in the house I am very
curious to see what the marriage between
the fantasy mystical side and the street
level side will feel
like well it's starting to accelerate
right like that soon is the first time
we've seen her actualize it it's
building to it yeah when didd you get
the call just before I called you 15
minutes ago man this guy's going to be a
bad guy yeah he moves like a fighter too
much heard from the other stops
transfers up and down that whole line
everyone did them exactly as usual d x
was no different so what are you saying
that's the one that blew we had nothing
to do with this we keep our heads down
and our mouths shut any crap rolls
downhill it won't land on you it'll land
on me and I brought plenty of bags
shouldn't he have texted that in sign
link
which little hand signal emojis don't
get it
guys she's officially back in town yeah
really oh uh upgrade look at all the
bows I really uh miss you around here 20
years way too
long I go um get things yeah Chop Chop
if uh somebody comes in just uh
holler oh fun it's like a comic book
panel yeah leg upgrade sure oh yeah he's
got to do some
modifications they're Armory
melted a job well done sir that in the
back holy
it's made of vibranium yeah the
real one take uh time for me to to build
that's temporary don't you run off with
it that's a
spare that's the woman from the vision
maybe she doesn't really understand her
Heritage that's a Chata aafa so speak
can to learn together o oh yeah when
they emerged turned into human beings
your uh grandmother
oh would Trace Your Roots back to uh
Chata aapa oh that's cool so it's that
direct line ancestors would watch out
for uh
family in times of need it's interesting
too that they gave this rendering an
actual fertility esque physique it's
like a detail I never would have
expected your grandmother knows all that
you U ask
her yeah I didn't ask to hear your life
story and by extension my life and our
people's life story enough of my own
upbringing
uhoh new car chola
whis get borrowed
man yes speak of the
[Music]
devil I don't think she saw you man I
think you're good that was amazing oh I
just admire it you
know have a good one
one that shot was perfect I showed up
for Kingpin and Maya but it's these
supporting characters who I think are
really elevated the show to another
level man it's been like 18 hours pok's
going to kill me I love you man he
really messed
up Biscuit's here again um pretty new
PlayStation and I'm not trying to brag
or nothing but you know I I wouldn't be
doing this if I didn't need the money to
figure my grandma's truck it's now at a
low low price of 100 bucks damn dude
I'll buy
it meetting Bonnie everyone's from
reservation
dogs what happened to the truck I was
driving in back roads and I might have
been a little distracted are you okay
and what what was the trouble no trouble
at all I'm okay Billy Jack's okay Maya's
okay but the truck it's oh no oh dude
man what Maya is here she's in
Maha did I say Maya I said jumbalaya I'm
losing you please uh call the chip life
you want buy play thank you biscuits
where is she over and out biscuits don't
you dare do this to
me a I really feel like the community
and the people everyone has distinct
personalities and they feel real they
feel alive yeah like they're off doing
stuff right now and I believe that in
the show which I don't often
[Laughter]
filled with
protein I think she
has that's a fair point already doing
business there though and she knows
itch introduce a little
[Music]
chaos ooh I like her color
scheme his name is
awesome just
low see even though they're at odds I
feel like this could be one of the
potential times where like a guy you
don't want to be a villain maybe falls
into that side of things but you but
maybe he's got like some kind of point
that they could articulate in a
sophisticated way yeah cuz her
indifference to everyone that she
actually does love is going to be like I
see an opportunity in a character like
that in a lot of these characters that
so many of these shows present and
squander and I hope they nail here
because they could because she obviously
needs to figure out how much she cares
about these people and he might be the
one to be right while she's wrong and
right
Bonnie oh no girls are always
fighting women am I
right
ouchie
shoot your way to the
Past damn thank you Georgia all
right all right
beautiful that was truly like a a a
under there wasn't a lot of action it
but it all the dialogue was so
action-packed like the end was the only
time like obviously the train scene but
they really let that be subdued I was
afraid this episode would end with like
a third
Act cof yeah that was really
cool he was in the trade is that not the
name of the
show there actually is a new comic
called darev EO it's pretty Dar devil
echo or is
he why isn't he in
Oklahoma if you went all the way to
She-Hulk land why didn't you come all
the way to echoland why isn't he helping
out the reservation land just everywhere
man he could be everywhere that's why
there so many opening credits why wasn't
he there should be white saving going on
why isn't Charlie Cox's top
billing why isn't he the original chak
yeah I think it's really good there is
this part in my mind is the problem with
social media rhetoric that can often
circulate and just the Optics around
Disney deciding to because they've been
toying with their release strategy I
actually really like what they did with
what if surprisingly that one a day that
sounded like a terrible idea first just
for our end and then then ended up
panning out really well just like how it
paded out really well for everyone who
bought a shirt at reject Nation shop.com
they really where you can I love I
always love John's
like transition whenever whenever I'm
the shirt he does the first the hair and
then look at my shirt I got to get the
hair out of the way see
Shir hair love I love your designs so
much and I just want to accentuate them
anyway thank you all who been buying
teas and uh you look good while doing it
too and I mean come on look at buff
comfortable oh my God that's what I like
to see that's what I like to see I
thought that this was a really solid
episode and I like everything that it's
building to my favorite part about the
show thus far and we're going to watch a
third episode just a little bit so I I'd
really prefer if we just kept this
really short I mean it gents is The
Supporting Cast I think The Supporting
Cast has really been a Saving Grace to
it because well I think everything's
shot really well I'm intrigued by the
chalk talk culture uh I I am a little
bit
like semi nervous about what what's It
ultimately going to meld into once we go
full uh chock toop mysticism because
it's the street level stuff that I find
the most intriguing at this moment in
time that but I'm completely open-minded
is seeing what they ultimately integrate
I think my one concern is pretty
apparent if you like actually watch the
reaction is that uh yeah I'm just not
super emotionally invested in Maya right
now and I I have no qualms or
apprehensions there was nothing about me
that was the least bit concerned about
someone who is uh deaf and that can keep
I feel like some people well is because
she can't talk that it could be a
limitation I'm like no some of my
favorite performances ever are usually
just quiet body language performances
with minimal dialogue so I didn't think
there would be some type of barrier
there uh right now I can't quite put my
finger on it granted it's just the
second episode but we did spend a decent
amount of time with her in Hawkeye while
I like her here more and while I like
what she serves as a plot narrative
device going forward it is everything
everyone and everything else surrounding
her I'm talking like in terms of
technicality of film making uh
cast everything around her I find way
more interesting than just her right now
and
that's my main is concern with the
journey moving forward that could all
that's all subject to change in like
literally one episode I'm not even quite
sure what it is that they need to do
because I felt like last episode they
bombarded us with a cacophony of
information about her and the and the
journey uh but there there is something
that is keeping me at a distance and I'm
not quite sure what it is just yet maybe
I'll be able to articulate it later on
uh but it's not at all detering me from
enjoying uh the show or right I think
it's like a cool criminal under I think
it's a Cool Crime world I like how it
develops into the MCU I think it's cool
that we're getting this Fisk expansion
um the the Shadow the pull that he casts
over everything is really neat so I
really I really am liking it uh but that
that is the one thing I guess not so
much a criticism but something I'm
craving right now craving the hunting
for it
COI I personally care more about Ekko
here than I did in Hawkeye as well but
it's starting to get I I I see what
you're saying uh by the end of this
episode I was starting to feel like I
wasn't thinking about that as much
because that that had affected me the
first episode and like half of this one
but with the Bonnie stuff and with the
character starting to come into her like
I feel like you know she's not in town
now that she's in town I'm like okay
we're all starting to bring these
disperate story lines to me caring about
Eko CU it's her relationship that's
starting to be more apparent and feel so
I think it's going to be for Me Maybe
for you as well kind of like lowkey
season 2 where we were both worried that
he was just like I'm an agent of the TVA
and then by episode five we were like oh
I I see why they had to build all that
to him so I think as long as that turn
happens I'll be okay but I definitely
understand where you're coming from now
I hope that happens uh I really like
that this show and I I think I Now
understand why they did this all as one
binge I think it's because the audience
they're appealing to isn't used to slow
content uh I think that you have a show
that is going to have a lot more
dialogue than action and I think that
people are probably waiting for third
act fight scenes or for big bads and I
think when you've got a 5H hour delivery
of something the things on social media
are going to be like deevil Fight King
Pin fight good and then they won't have
to worry about people not talking about
like the dialogue scenes that would
inevitably not be part of social
conversation so I think the release
model is now starting to make more sense
to me with this particular show because
this episode I really enjoyed but I'm
not necessarily the target demo anymore
uh I like slowburn True Detectives shows
I like more drama and so I think my my
attention span after growing up with VHS
is aware that this exists and not all of
their demo is so I think releasing these
day and date might actually work out for
their favor because social media
reactions will be about other things
yeah so I'm enjoying especially get your
Netflix characters over here with a
model that resembles something more of
Netflix this definitely feels more HBO
Netflix and I think that'll be the
conversation yeah yeah yeah I no I think
it's a lot of Pros I think there's like
like it's primarily a a Pros experience
this is in my upper half of of Disney
Plus show so far yeah I like her more
than iron fist I like I like the
character of Eko more than iron fist but
but at least he was like enjoyably
bad yes that's true and Defenders we
could all be like why are they going to
him so much we got get these guys over
here my favorite part about him but yeah
I I'm enjoying this more than I expected
um and I think that it feels a lot more
like uh David Mack art than I expected
it's got a really wonderful pacing and
and it feels like the opening the
opening credits if I'd seen separately
I'd be like they're really trying to be
True Detective but the show actually
feels like that kind of grit yeah yeah
I'm not saying it's his darkest D
detective I'm saying so far it's earned
its opening credits yeah yeah yeah I'm
curi I I I agree with pretty much
everything that you guys have expressed
I liked all the things that you guys
like John Wiz he agrees everything
I I think I have uh a a guess as to what
might not fully be clicking together
here because uh I was kind of noticing
it during the episode and I do think
it's interesting that they have so many
people cast from reservation dogs
because what I love the most so far
about this is the times when it's
reminding me of that show because that
show has a very unique strange but also
very intimate kind of tone where you
feel like you're just absorbing the vibe
of the both indigenous culture and this
a town kind of like this and so I feel
like it's neat that they pulled these
actors together and when you're focusing
on that stuff it's when it feels the
most organic and like a real story and
that stuff kind of helps Maya's
character because everyone's like is she
back what do we do about it like
everyone's so kind of up in arms about
her but I feel like when you go to Maya
she's kind of just in this Lone Wolf
action badass story and like all the
interesting nuanced character beats are
mostly through other people and this
episode introduces the idea of like okay
she's going to have some you know
magical link to the the first Chaka and
the power that lies within and that in
the moment I was like oh this feels like
Miss Marvel like this this feels kind of
something directly pulled from Playbook
it doesn't feel quite as fleshed as when
you're just with the towns folk in
they're dealing with you know like what
were you doing out with the car this
train hey what do you know about this
and everyone's kind of like shuffling
truths around that stuff feels nuanced
and then you also have the third show
which is you know Daredevil and Kingpin
and like that and I like that we
don't have to be always doing that I
like that that can have distance but
still affect where we are here but I do
feel like there are three shows
happening one of them is a very pleasant
surprise that you're like man if they
could sustain this and and yeah merge
all of these this could be something
really really special and uh I I can
still see the potential for that but it
was during the train sequence where I
was torn because I was like this is cool
I like a low light kind of set piece
like this but I also was finding myself
like not checked out but just like kind
of at a plateau of of thrill in that
moment uh and I'm like if I if we had
maybe a couple more intimate moments
with Maya or times to see her soften or
deal with the struggles that she's not
maybe going to show to everybody else
because she's got to maintain that tough
face that that demeanor you know I feel
like if we could get some moments to
peer into her with a Nuance versus the
requisite stuff that we a know about her
and B often feeds the backstory of a
character like this I feel like that
would pull it all together but uh as it
stands right now I like all the elements
that they have and I believe that they
can accentuate them all to the utmost
but yeah it's like there are three
things I like Happening Here one of them
I think is pretty pretty great one of
them's pretty good and the other one I'm
like yeah this is the meat and potatoes
that you need to do a badass you know
again Lone Wolf taking it to the Man
kind of story but uh that's the piece
I'm waiting for the the most like reason
to connect to beyond all the requisit
stuff because of what kind of show
you're watching yeah um I feel like
there's more to definitely
say uh in terms of what may be working
or way not be working however
this is designed to be a binge
experience so I'm going to reserve I'm
going to intentionally hold back
intentionally hold back some stuff so
that way I'm just not like next episode
like never
mind it'll be easier just to kind of
give a full encapsulated review uh once
we're done with the fifth episode so Al
righty guys uh what do you what do you
what do you think about Maya huh yeah
there you go that's a question want to
name my band plateau of thrill I don't
know what to say we play Red deaded to
put it down would you rob a train leave
it in the comments the best vehicle to
Rob uh subscribe leave a like thank you
to everyone who about see us for the
next episode cheers
peeps Lex it is time for your patron of
the day shout out your first one for
2024 and I got to Fathom what your New
Year's resolution is and that is to buy
more batteries I can understand that
running out of batteries it's a pain in
the ass sometimes you're like trying to
turn on the TV you look forever for that
remote and then you're like okay here it
is time to turn on the television and
then bam you can't turn it on because
there's no batteries in there it is a
very frustrating process once in a while
you want to take out one of your toys
you know to pleasure yourself but then
bam batteries don't work so you call up
your mom you're like Mom I need
batteries for my action figure like what
action figure you still play with action
figures Lex I never knew you play with
action
figures I just need batteries mom can
you please drop off some batteries and
then she's like well send me a photo
then you send her a photo of it that
leads to an awkward conversation and
then you go damn I should have followed
through my New Year's
resolution a year supply of batteries
yeah doublea's aaa's D's Vol now you got
to have an awkward ass conversation with
your mom cuz you were irresponsible you
didn't stick to your goals yeah list
next time L for list Lex you get a
pretty good deal on Amazon always double
a AAA MCO they'll drive a drone to your
house I don't know why you didn't do it
Lex not my family problem now yeah it's
okay anyway good luck with 2024 dealing
with this
trauma again
[Music]